hey everybody welcome to another
rollback today we're rolling back the
clock all the way to May of
2015. to discuss our misplaced obsession
with a little macronutrient you might
have heard of called protein and we're
doing it with Dr Garth Davis Dr Davis is
a veteran weight loss surgeon and
obesity medicine specialist who after
years and years of practicing medicine
with no real serious education
surrounding nutrition takes it upon
himself to determine exactly why so many
people are plagued by obesity it's a
quest that led him to identify the
ultimate human diet to maximize Health
what is that diet I'm sure you can guess
it's a plant-based diet Dr Davis is also
the author of proteinaholic which
deconstructs our misplaced obsession
with protein and makes the case for
embracing our inner herbivore for not
only maintaining our weight 8 but also
for achieving maximum health and even
optimal athletic prowess in this episode
recorded in the pre-video days of the
show we cover high fat low carb diets we
cover bad science and how to separate
nutritional fact from popular fiction I
sincerely hope you enjoy it and get
something out of it so here we go this
is me and Dr Garth Davis
thank you
the first time we went into uh you know
all about kind of like your your story
and and your Evolution into what you do
and for listeners that that want to kind
of probe that in more depth they can go
back and listen to that episode I'll put
the link up in the show notes but I kind
of wanted today to
um
delve into a couple issues with more
specificity and detail if we could
over the last couple weeks
I've been a guest on like a bazillion
podcast because you know trying to get
the book out and doing all these
interviews and and the like and I just
did one the other day and the guy kind
of you know basically like a Paleo slant
podcast and the guy is kind of it with a
smile on his face ambushed me a little
bit you know he had spent a whole day
preparing for the interview and he got
he had all these studies in front of him
and it was a Skype call and he's like
well what about this study and what
about that study and I felt completely
ill-equipped to respond spontaneously in
the moment because I didn't have all my
you know Counterpoint studies in front
of me and and I felt like a little bit
like
not unprepared but a little bit like I
guess ambushed it's just the best that's
their motives yeah and so I I got off
the I got off the call and I was like I
just didn't feel that great about it you
know and it's like I'm not a guy who's
spending all my time mired in the
research and reading all these studies
like you are so I thought it would be a
good opportunity to kind of delve into
that a little bit and I just got an
email that I wanted to read
that came in from a follower uh this guy
Alex and he said uh
hey Rich I really enjoy your podcast
I've been roughly following the
bulletproof diet for years now and
appreciate the critical analysis of some
of the new high fat High meat Trends
however I'm not convinced that these are
misguided in reference to your
discussion with Joel Khan and there's a
hyperlink to something blah blah blah
much of the data con sighted seemed to
be correlational as well and his
discussion seemed to involve a method a
methodological
critique of the profat studies
co-founding variables reliable subjects
Etc not granted to the anti-fat research
the discussion was very level-headed and
reasonable but and I'm referencing
myself here too it seems very difficult
to get away from the quote my team
versus yours unquote mentality beyond
the advice to stop eating twinkies and
playing Starcraft it doesn't quite seem
like a quote objective road map exists
for nutritional choices and I think you
know it's a fair it's it's a fair
observation for him to make and I think
we are in this kind of scenario where
there's teams you know beating up on
each other and and you know I'm always
trying to just get to the objective
truth like I'm much less interested in
being a member of a team right than
truly having an in-depth comprehensive
understanding of the nutritional
landscape when it comes to plant-based
paleo ketosis low-fat high fat you know
all these sorts of ideas that are
floating around right now with varying
degrees of popularity yeah
the the Modis out there right now
you got to understand a few things about
science first of all you pull your mic
up a little bit closer to you sorry
about that okay is that better yeah it's
about a little echoey
um the first thing I understand about
science there's all kinds of researchers
out there and they live in this world of
publisher Parish that's their job if
they don't publish they get fired and
because of that there is a lot of really
bad research that comes out a lot of it
that's very sloppily done there is a
journal for every kind of thought
process you could have
um you know a lot of these journals are
are really poorly done they're not well
peer reviewed and yet what happens in
this day and age in these arguments
about nutrition is someone will be
um they'll be like okay Rich Roll said
this I'm going to prove him wrong I'm
going to go on to PubMed and I'm going
to find an article first article comes
up that's the article that they use
they never read the full article they
don't have a statistics background so
they don't know how to analyze
statistics
they don't know the people that are
publishing it they don't know the
confounding factors that may have been
involved
and yet they use it as fact and so what
what happens is they pigeonhole you
saying well you say this but I've got an
article that says that and it makes
those two articles seem equal when in
fact they're not and when you say well
your article is wrong and say oh now
you're just jumping from one thing to
the other I call these guys denialists
all right and so denialists do several
things first of all they try to take
down Authority so I hear people all the
time saying oh Dean owners you know Dean
ornish has been debunked what what do
you mean dean wonders right well the the
the cousin to that is The China Study
has been devoted yeah that gets thrown
around like like crazy right right and
if you say it hasn't then you're an
insane person yeah you're the same
person and look I could actually there
are things with The China Study that I
can find fault with but teen owners
definitely not but this idea that even
if you found fault with some parts of
The China Study Colin Campbell spent his
whole life studying nutrition he's done
benchtop research he's done randomized
price control trial research and he's
done really huge epidemiologic research
you should at least respect his opinion
this idea that he's been debunked is
absolutely ridiculous the other thing
that they they tend to do is that you
will hear them say this all the time
correlation does not equal causation
and this is true like for instance uh
there's more chocolate eaten in
Switzerland and Switzerland has more
Nobel Prize winners so somehow childhood
related now that is called a univariate
analysis meaning you're just taking two
variables and that's the only kind of
thing that you're gonna measure it's
chocolate and it's Nobel prizes to do a
scientific study though we do what's
called multivariate regression analysis
meaning we find everything that could
possibly be a confounding Factor you
know
um and we remove that out of the study
so that there's no confounding Factor so
that if we get a statistical significa
significance it may not mean causation
but where there's smoke there's fire and
then if you take
huge numbers of people studying the many
years in many different countries and
you start doing these retro these um
multivariate analyzes on them and you
come up with the same answer and all
these different studies you better start
listening to that it's really good
science the last thing that these people
do is they try to hold up that the only
without a doubt the best that he could
do on someone is a randomized controlled
uh Placebo blinded study but you can't
do that with food right you know I can I
can't do a study where I'm going to
follow 20 people for 20 years on you
know three different diets it's not
going to happen people don't uh people
don't live their lives like that and and
and and and they don't just eat one
thing right and they all have you know
varying degrees of of the way in which
they live their life brings up you know
a bazillion variables that you can
possibly begin to account for I mean so
many various look at there's um you know
I I often refer to the Epic trials which
is one of the largest studies ever done
on nutrition
much bigger than China Study or any of
that and what they looked at is 500 000
people over I think 10 to 12 countries
in Europe
they followed it now 12 to 14 years and
they're looking at different
correlations between what you eat how
much of it you eat in disease processes
that you get and and the the extent to
which they go to eliminate confounding
factors is incredible
um but they're still like they've got
vegans that they look at vegans that are
in Oxford but those vegans aren't
necessarily healthy because like you
look at those vegans
and they're only eating 18 grams of
fiber a day how does an vegan only get
18 grams of 500 a day so and they
weren't eating their B12 so there's so
many variables that it's very hard to
say Vegan is a good diet or bad diet
based on on these but there is what
people Miss is there's a huge
huge literature about plant-based diets
and about eating meat and a person who's
experienced in reading this literature
understanding it can make pretty good
conclusions and it is not as relative as
people make it out to be so what would
be in the most General sense some of
those conclusions based on the studies
and the research that you've kind of
immersed yourself oh yeah um without a
doubt processed meat is horrible for you
you can't get away from that fact so
processed meat bacon
um you know the Subway sandwich uh you
know cold cuts horrible for you related
with diabetes cancer life expectancy
heart disease horrible for you
red meat
um for the most part looks like it is
not good for you definitely associated
with diabetes definitely associated with
diabetes I'm not
quite sure you could be vegan and be
diabetic I know there's about a two
percent uh incidence of this but I don't
understand it I like to see those people
more clearly and there's a lot of
studies that go on with that
um
animal products in general well it seem
to be leading to premature aging in many
of the studies definitely a link with
cancer different Meats with different
cancers for for instance chicken is
strongly related with
um
um lymphoma and Leukemia whereas meat is
strongly related with colon cancers and
uh and some of the other reproductive
cancers
um prostate is very very strongly linked
with dairy eggs and meat
um definitely a heavy animal protein
diet is associated with heart disease
definitely is associated with high blood
pressure and it's definitely associated
with a shorter length of life and the
interesting thing about the longevity
studies is we talked about taking out
confounding factors
if you take out a lot of confounding
factors you get to the point where
you're almost taking away a correlation
and yet after really rigorous
statistical analysis there's still a
finding that if you eat a plant-based
diet or if you eat less meat you live
longer interesting well I mean those are
some pretty
you know bold statements that fly in the
face of what seems to be quite popular
right now which is you know we can go
through them you know in a bullet point
way but why don't we just start with
saturated fat right there's this sort of
populist notion at the moment backed by
certain studies that basically says
everything you ever heard about
saturated fat is wrong saturated fat is
not your enemy and it's not linked to
the incidence of heart disease is that a
fair characterization of kind of where a
certain school of thought is coming from
actually the school of thought has gone
worse they now say saturated fat is good
for you right so you'll you'll see those
things you know bacon is good they know
the funny how I saw an article bacon is
good for you and it wasn't about any
testing of bacon being good for you it
was about saturated fat being good for
you now the studies that you mentioned
that um called the question saturated
fat
um they never said saturated fat is good
for you that's not their comma they
questioned whether it was a strongly
correlated with heart disease as we
previously thought now the main study a
study called Siri Torino is a perfect
example of over adjusting your
statistical analysis
keep in mind every author on that
article was paid for or receives payment
from either make meat milk or dairy
what's that study called it's the Siri
Torino study
s-i-r-i-t-a-r-i-n-o that is the study
that really started it all that's the
study that all these you know
journalists like Tobbs and um
yeah that's the one they just jumped on
and went with it and was that the basis
of the Time Magazine butter is back
article absolutely yeah it's the basis
of every article they that ever comes
out and so what did that study say so
they they looked at a bunch of studies
and they said
um basically that saturated fat is not
correlated with heart disease but here's
the problem first of all
you hear this term thrown around a lot
called cherry picking where they
cherry-picked articles that would
basically give their answer because I
could have done that same study and
brought a whole different group of
Articles it got in a completely
different
analysis but we'll put cherry picking
aside the problem is a lot of the
studies that they picked did something
called over adjustment so what they did
it's just like we talked about before if
we're gonna do a study and we're going
to remove confounding variables meaning
variables that might affect
independently affect the results so
we're trying to see if saturated fat
causes heart disease so we want to take
out other things that may affect heart
disease so for instance if you're
diabetic we're taking you out when
you're not in the study and we'll look
at our population we'll say well if
you're morbidly obese we know that
independently affects that's what we're
going to take out
now funny the more you take out the more
you're taking out away from people that
you know like plant-based diet benefits
and stuff like that but
here's the key they took out people that
had high cholesterol those highest
cholesterol is an independent cause of
heart disease but saturated fat causes
heart disease by raising cholesterol
in part
so by removing those people from there
you're removing the people that actually
are affected by the saturated fat you're
leaving for the study people that have a
genetic predisposition where they could
eat saturated fat not raise their
cholesterol and therefore won't get
heart disease it's ridiculous now the
second study that came along was a study
by child artery and it was in I think
it's in the British Journal of Medicine
and that study did the same kind of
things as the Siri Torino study did but
on top of it there were people that were
on Lipitor while doing the study so
they're taking a drug that's supposed to
get rid of the effects of saturated fat
and then they're eating saturated fat
and not getting hard that wasn't taken
into account no into the that's
interesting yeah
so all right so then that begs the
question of the impact of cholesterol on
heart disease and I and I guess that
means you have to talk about the
difference between
um you know sort of serum cholesterol
and dietary cholesterol right the
difference between eating
cholesterol-laden foods and the impact
of that on cholesterol and what that
causes in terms of health yeah I mean
eating cholesterol does raise
cholesterol the only place we get
cholesterol is from animal products
um
and cholesterol definitely is associated
with heart disease now the problem is
we've gotten a little bit more
scientific nowadays so we don't just
look at cholesterol per se however the
largest study that's been done looking
at cholesterol in America in a
population was the Framingham study and
Dr castelli himself said that possibly
the problem we have is that we set what
we call a normal cholesterol too high
and that a normal cholesterol should
actually be lower and he noted that
under a total cholesterol of 150 they
never in all the years they studied
Framingham saw anybody with heart
disease he said if you keep your total
cholesterol under 150 you're not going
to get heart disease we're more specific
now when I see someone with a high
cholesterol I want to know their LDL
particle size their APO B protein I mean
there's a there's a specific type of
cholesterol that's dangerous
and if you have that specific type of
cholesterol that needs to be addressed
then you need to be on you know
seriously low fat and and what is the uh
impact of ingesting cholesterol dietary
cholesterol on your cholesterol levels
because isn't part of this idea or this
argument that that dietary cholesterol
is not impactful on those cholesterol
levels yeah and it's it's just silly
um without a doubt if you eat
cholesterol but here's the problem
and it's a big problem with our
nutrition in general we get down into
what's called reductionist food science
we try to take
you know one part of a food away it's
like nothing bothers me more than when
I'm ordering a salad and the waiter says
would you like a protein with that salad
because I and then I always protein yeah
I always have to pick on them and you
know don't poor guy had to get me at the
table and you know then I'm always like
well you know what do you mean he's like
well do you want chicken or steak and
I'm like well there's more calories from
fat and chicken so are you really just
asking me if I want some fat with my
salad yeah and the guy's like uh uh you
know I'm gonna get into a nutrition
debate with the waiter right you know
but I think it's interesting that now I
have noticed that they'll say you know
what would you like for your protein as
opposed to what meat you know like
that's a weird vernacular shift that
didn't exist a couple years ago
absolutely my son got into a debate at
Chipotle the other day when they he was
they were going down the line and
building the burrito and the guy says
what would you like for for meat
entire sound I'm not going to have meat
and uh and he's like but I'll have uh
I'll have this sofritis which is the
basically their medium tofu thing and uh
and he's like well that's meat and
Tyler's like no that's not me and he's
like yeah that's meat and I'm like come
on let's just keep moving this is not
gonna go anywhere you're not going to
teach this guy right here yeah but but
the point being you know that we're in
this reductionist food science where we
try to we're trying to tease away parts
of food that stick together so there's
no time that you're ever gonna just eat
cholesterol you know the cholesterol is
always going to be tied with fat you
know it's part of the fat
um and so it's very hard to measure the
same with just you know I for years I
tried to sift through studies looking at
animal protein but it's really hard to
sift the fact that you know animal
proteins got saturated fat connected to
it and has cholesterol connected to it
so is it the cholesterol is it the
saturated fat is it the animal protein
we can make some judgment as to what it
is
but really it's the whole package and
really we should be talking about the
whole package I mean the studies would
be a lot easier if the study just looked
at you know meat and stopped talking
about saturated fat right because if
somebody says well I need that animal
protein well that comes with a lot of
other things right that that don't get
looked at and It's tricky because you
know the reductionist approach is
inherently flawed in that regard as you
pointed out but there really isn't a
better way to look at it you know so
what else are you supposed to do
otherwise you'll get lost in a morass of
of data that's meaningless yeah it's you
know I there's been a change in the
actual science and when I say actual
science everybody's online reading
nonsense okay they're not reading the
actual journals you know when they
debate with you their reference is
another person's blog which always makes
me laugh in fact one guy was like oh
yeah this art he put up an article that
was actually against what he was saying
but people don't know how to read the
science okay so when when you actually
read the science there's been a move now
in a lot of these big epidemiologic
studies to not try to tease away
saturated fat or any of that stuff and
just look at what are the quintiles and
of meat consumption in other words
there's the lowest quintile the second
Quint out there quintile fourth fifth
and let's compare them together and see
if we see a change and so in the study
like what are the studies that that you
look at and and find most
um you know objective and informative
and instructional with respect to how
you
um devise your treatment protocols for
your patients sure and someone asked me
this once before a Paleo guy and he said
because I was complaining about and
there's so much of this the involvement
of industry and science because the
industry they know just like with
tobacco if they could put a seed of
doubt in someone's mind
they can make them say well I don't know
if meat's good I don't know if it's bad
so I'm going to eat it right and that's
what Fusion plays into their confusion
is exactly what they want and so they
love this confusion going on
and so I don't like these bias in a lot
of the Articles so if I read an article
and I see that there's bias in it that
immediately doesn't discredit the
article but you know raises eyebrows and
a lot of times it's not the data that
they're doing that's bad it's the
interpretation that the people read so
I'll go through the data you know and
look at the charts and stuff and say
well you know their conclusion is not
exactly what I read I'll give you an
example that later
um but so someone said to me well they
might have bias but don't you have your
own bias I mean aren't you vegan
and I had to think about that for a
while because yeah I am biased in that
regard I'm worried about the environment
I'm worried about the senseless
Slaughter of animals for no reason or uh
or or the way they're killed but
there's two sides to me I really think
like if if we came if an article came
out and said there's no benefit to a
plant-based diet whatsoever I would stop
recommending that to patients and I
didn't recommend it until I got the
science and I would be vegan and say
look don't kill animals because it's
mean to kill animals that's I started
this without the vegans component of it
I started this based on on Pure Health
and as the more and more I've learned
I've really really started looking at
the health and what really convinced me
were several studies so
there's the Epic study I talked about is
as unbiased as possible I mean this is
really a conglomerate of the European
Union these are some of the top
epidemiological scientists that if you
read a paper there's like 100 authors
for each paper they looked at their food
questionnaires that they used they made
sure that they were culture specific
they tested them to make sure that they
were accurate this is a really good
science and the data is not absolutely
clear with it they don't the data does
not say go vegan but it definitely
points towards the fact that animal
protein is associated with weight gain
diabetes heart disease and length and
Longevity problems
um and I like it because it's many
different societies and it's a long-term
study and it there's just so many people
500 000 people it's huge
um when was that study conducted and
still going on it started in the early
2000s and still going on so they're
building this gigantic database is there
uh like a good uh link online where
people can see that or at least find
information about that
um if you just look up epic epic uh epic
Panacea
um there's a they've got their Central
website which kind of explains it
um there are so many articles on PubMed
they had an international Consortium
kind of going over all the data they've
had so far last year
whether they made strong reference to
the fact that protein was associated
with diabetes
and
strong fact to the strong reference to
the fact that protein causes weight gain
and both were in there but there's many
different articles that go through there
um the one of the head authors of your
PubMed searching is virgno
v-e-r-g-n-a-u-d uh and he's done some
really good science well I don't know if
it's him it's his team but yeah
um and you know there's they have a
certain group of epics so you can go
into the Epic data and they look
specifically at Epic Oxford because
Oxford's kind of interesting because
there they have healthy meat eaters so
they don't eat meat nearly as much as
the rest of the country and they
um live a healthy lifestyle
and they wanted to compare them to
vegans to see if there's been again I
told you those vegans were not healthy
vegans yeah it's it's there's this idea
that a vegan is a vegan right you know
what I mean that's a whole you know
spectrum of ways of eating yeah like I
told you yeah I was telling you I went
to a vegan junk food restaurant because
when you're in La you do those things
yeah and I had a bacon cheeseburger oh
my God it tastes just like what I
remember bacon cheeseburgers tastes like
but felt so sick afterwards and that's
definitely not healthy so if you're
eating that you're not a healthy vegan
yeah there's so many I mean now you can
get so much vegan junk food so much
which is like great and terrible at the
same time exactly
um but
still when they look at the Epic Oxford
the vegans tend to do better than the uh
meat eaters the one spot they didn't was
colon cancer which is bizarre because
vegans always do better in colon cancer
but it may just be that these vegans
were not eating much fiber only a lot of
processed food
other studies I love
the Harvard studies are really good
they're following the the Harvard
studies they followed
nurses for many years now I think 20 30
years the nurse's health study and
they've done the same with health
professionals
um men that were doctors health
professionals they followed them for
many years and they've looked at diet
patterns
the only problem with that study is
there's not there's hard to find a
difference if everyone's eating the same
thing in other words if you've got a
group that's eating meat three times a
day another group that's eating meat two
times a day can you really make a
correlation or really make a judgment
pattern that's that's a little bit of a
problem with theirs was pretty good my
favorite studies are the advanced health
study because I said you can't do a
long-term study where you make someone
vegan and you make someone a meat eater
but that's happening in Loma Linda
California because the Seventh-Day
Adventists believe that the body is the
Temple of the soul and it should be
treated as such so the whole group is
healthy they are very similar exercise
patterns they live in the same
environment exposed to the same toxins
but some of them are vegan some will do
milk and Dairy some will eat fish and
some will eat meat and they've got low
meat eaters and high meat eaters so
they've got this already partitioned off
group of people that have a different
level of consumption of these meats and
their data is very very convincing and
that's probably my favorite study so the
event is healthy study and that and that
data suggests what I definitely suggests
that a plant-based diet is better for
you I mean
they've got very strong data showing a
plant-based diet prevents uh diabetes
very strong data that it prevents heart
disease very strong data that it
prevents cancer
um fish does well in that group but in
the other ones not as much and then just
length of Life the vegans live longer
than the other groups yeah there's that
uh that cardiologist Dr Ellsworth yeah I
saw them the other day oh you did yeah
yeah it's almost five or something guys
I think he's 100 and he's 100 now the
surgeon yeah yeah yeah but he practiced
until
yeah he just seems like such a nice guy
sweet guy yeah amazing
um all right so you know that's all
interesting you know and I'm I'm just
thinking
um you know how does that
like how does it how does it happen that
you see these studies you understand
them you're convinced and yet at the
same time you know right now we're all
being told that you know we need to eat
more protein we're in this massive you
know protein push right uh plant protein
is is is uh
not as Superior to The Human Condition
and health as animal protein you know
look at you and me wasting away
and uh and that saturated fat is not a
problem meanwhile uh is it the USDA that
is suggesting that we shouldn't worry
about cholesterol anymore I think that
the USDA is kind of like look we're
going to tell you to eat less meat and
we're going to tell you to eat less fat
and that'll take care of the cholesterol
but in order you know the the lobbyists
are on them oh yeah so I think this is a
little flag hey we'll give you back your
cholesterol because they're not gonna be
able to eat it anyway because they're
not supposed to be eating meat well the
politics behind that are pretty
extraordinary I mean for The Listener
right now the USDA is that every four
years has to come up with their dietary
guidelines and they in panel like a
group of advisors to help suggest how
they might make changes to you know that
nutrition sort of pyramid or plate or
whatever it is these days and for the
first time ever they're suggesting uh
eating less meat for health reasons but
also for sustainability reasons and this
has caused quite the stir amongst the
meat and dairy Lobby people who are up
in arms that sustainability or
environmental concern should even play a
part at all in dietary recommendations
and so there's all these congressmen and
Senators who have constituencies and you
know the heartland of America who are
petitioning the USDA that they've
overstepped their boundaries and that
this is you know this is not their job
right I mean you ask the question how
are we all so confusing because of the
industry I mean it's not a conspiracy
theory it's a fact I mean they're
everywhere they're
um you could go back to the 70s when
they had the Senate select commission
then the government commission that got
together to find out why we were getting
more and more heart disease and they did
huge rounds of uh research and came up
with the idea that we need to eat less
meat and uh that was completely the the
meat industry jumped on it got McGovern
voted out got the committee disbanded
and it was all you could watch it in
place you could watch it happening and
it still happens now but the other
problem is the medical profession in
general because
the medical profession is not designed
to treat a whole person
um for you know the GI doctor treats the
stomach the heart doctor treats the
heart and when we were in residency and
there was a patient we didn't even call
him by their name it was like you know
the colon cancer in room two and you
know I'd go in and examine the patient
you know and would Dive Right for their
stomach you know I'm not asking them how
they're feeling what are they eating we
do these like complex history and
physicals and yet I never ask them what
they eat you know I got you know all the
subscure stuff but I don't ask them
probably the most important question
what are you eating
and so it's very hard for a doctor that
we don't learn any nutrition I mean any
nutrition in medical school so it's very
hard for a doctor
to even think about nutrition and I've
talked to doctors about this many times
number one they're reading journals that
have to do with their specialty they're
not reading the nutrition journals
number two
even if they thought like I gave I gave
a talk to this endocrine society and
I've got so much data showing the
correlation between meat and uh and
diabetes it's crazy it's very hard to
argue with and so the endocrinologists
are like okay that's probably true but
listen my patients aren't going to
change they're not going to do it
they're not going to do it so why do I
even worry about that instead I'm just
going to give them a medicine
in addition that's a terrible mindset
it's a terrible mindset but that's what
they're built with and you know what
it's easy to sit and say that's a
terrible mindset it's much harder when
you're sitting across from a patient and
you've got 20 minutes with a patient and
you got to tell them to change their
whole lifestyle and how they eat it's
not so easy and patients don't do it I
mean I experience this all the time no I
I'm in a little bit of an advantage
because I've got this big office with
dietitians and psychologists and I spend
more time with them and but for for an
endocrinologist to sit there and like
let me tell you about plant-based diet
very difficult not impossible but very
difficult the other thing is that as a
doctor you know I hear people say oh
doctors just want to keep you sick
that's not the reason it's not like
doctors are in this conspiracy to keep
people sick that's really nonsense
um but the system is set up to diagnose
and prescribe and that's exactly there
is an economy around that that in order
for it to sustain itself and for
everybody to you know profit off of it
it has to work a certain way right but
the doctor's not thinking I need to
write the script because I need to
profit off it the doctor's thinking my
job is to write a script like a patient
comes in there's a problem I got to do
something about it you know how they say
men always have to fix something well
doctors always have to fix something too
it's that it's this notion that uh that
it's broken I got to do something to fix
it so I'm going to throw this and
they'll and they'll put medicines on
there that will give a temporary fix but
you know aren't going to have a
long-term fix now on the flip side the
scientists
they really do miss the forest for the
trees so to speak so they
they just don't have any clinical
realm to understand how their data fits
in so I was at a scientific meeting and
this lady was giving this um excellent
review of her research that showed that
heme iron which is the iron that's in
animal protein
is very damaging to the islet cells of
the pancreas that secrete insulin
hmm
and the data was very convincing and at
the end you know there's question
sessions and someone got up and they
asked them they said okay well with all
you've learned what kind of diet do you
follow and she was kind of taken aback
she goes oh well I do a high protein low
carb diet and I mean I I almost wanted
to fall out of the chair I'm like you
just told us that heme iron is bad for
your pancreas she's overweight
she also talked about heme iron and its
oxidative problems and how it could make
you overweight and things like that and
then you say that you eat a high protein
diet which is high Heen diets you might
as well I said I just I eat exactly the
opposite of my clinical findings right
and and for the listener the pro the
iron that's found in plants is non-heem
it's a different type of iron and that's
also often pointed towards as a reason
to not adopt a plant-based diet
particularly if you're an athlete that
the non-heme variety of iron is
um is sort of uh insufficient I suppose
in terms of carrying oxygen to your
blood or whatever it is that it's
supposed to do it doesn't do it as well
as the heme variety which is unfounded
and not true there's so many things that
are said that are just like so
completely untrue I just wonder where it
starts I think what happens is some
blogger just says it and then you know
they tell two people and they tell two
people and then all of a sudden
there it is true that vegans tend to be
have a little bit lower iron
but not anemic they don't have any
higher incidence of anemia yeah I heard
that that the the incidence of anemia is
pretty much uniform across you know
vegan and meat eaters which is
surprising because I think that is one
of the ideas that if you're going to be
vegan you got to watch out for your iron
and you might become anemic I mean I
have so many meat-eating anemic patients
it's unbelievable and the funny become
anemic if you're eating a high protein
animal based diet well I mean there's
many different reasons you can develop
gastritis you could have diverticulitis
you can
um have um pernicious anemia where your
stomach has a problem producing factors
that help you absorb different vitamins
that help you make blood cells there's
many different ways the funny thing to
me though is that if someone's on a
vegan diet
that is the answer to any problem that
they have when they see another doctor
you know patients will come to me
they'll be like my doctor says you know
I'm anemic so I need to go off my vegan
diet I'm like what does he tell us meat
eaters that are anemic or they'll say
I'm hypothyroid my doctor says it's
because of my vegan diet I'm like what
about the millions of hypothyroid meat
eaters it's because it's a mystery I
think to most doctors and it's an easy
thing to point out that is distinguishes
you from the typical patient that
they're going to see right exactly and
and because they don't fully understand
it it's you can just identify it as it
must be the culprit yeah and I find a
lot of doctors find it offensive somehow
like they feel like um I'm going to tell
you what's right for you you know when I
didn't tell you to go on the vegan diet
so it's got to be wrong for you they
almost the animals don't want to be
proved wrong you know that's interesting
yeah well it's so bizarre because when
you look at a whole food plant-based
diet I mean you know unless I'm missing
something it pretty much seems to be the
ultimate way to prevent and reverse
chronic lifestyle disease no matter what
form or shape that may take and so to
the extent that it could be identified
as the problem that's leading towards
your malady just seems ironic yeah and
sometimes this is crazy to me I mean I
get a talk recently to a bunch of
bariatric doctors I mean these are
doctors that are dealing with people
with weight issues
and what we're feeling what we're
finding out now with in weight loss
surgeries people start to regain the
weight after a while
and so they're in this conference
talking about people that are regaining
weight and they're talking about what
other surgery can we do for their regain
awake no one is mentioning food at all
so I was one of the speakers and I got
up there and I said how many of you have
heard of the Epic study and this is the
biggest study ever on food and nutrition
not a single person raised their hand
how many of you bariatric surgeons yeah
how many of you have studied the nurses
health study zero hands anybody know
about the advanced health study zero
hands so there's just so uneducated
about this stuff and the thing that
kills me is but it's not because they're
they're lazy it's not even their fault
like they're just busy living their
lives and trying to do what they do yeah
I mean bariatric surgery
you know the act of cutting the stomach
making it smaller bypassing it it works
they get their results so they think
that's all I need you know in the
surgeon World a chance to cut is a
chance to cure and that's all that's
going through their mind that's but
that's a display of the problem you know
for the heart doctor it's a chance to
give someone lipitors a chance to save
alive a chance to yeah but these are
these are these are addressing symptoms
right not the underlying cause that's
leading that patient to get to that
place because that's what medical school
does it teaches you to treat symptoms it
doesn't treat you to teach a larger
cause it doesn't teach
food as medicine
and that's one of the central things
that we have to deal with that's what
really one of the biggest problems and
it kills me because look you get someone
like Dean orders you put it all together
right you have to have you can't there's
no one study that puts it all together
but like Dean did some really
interesting stuff recently so there was
a lot of epidemiologic data that shows
that meat consumption correlates with
prostate cancer
if you look at parts of the world where
they've done a lot of prostate cancer
they don't eat a lot of meat now some
people said well that might be because
they're just not pick testing they're
not testing for prostate cancer okay
that's possible but we they look
specifically at Japan where they did a
very strong testing protocol where they
had very low rates of prostate cancer
and then they looked at migration
studies where Japanese men moved to
America boom they're getting prostate
cancer so there's not kind of any
genetic protection
so Dean took a group of people that had
a high PSA diagnosed prostate cancer but
it refused therapy they didn't want any
therapy
and so he put one group into his
lifestyle medicine which is meditation
exercise and a vegan diet I wish you
would just I wish you would separate
that up a bit because yeah because I
think that's a it it opens him up to
criticism people say well he gets people
to quit smoking and he gets them to
start exercising and so how can you
really say what it is that's impacting
yeah I believe a lot in meditation but I
don't think meditation stopped the
prostate cancer cells here that's as
much as I'll say the um other group just
did a conventional stuff they did as I
remember I go through so many studies
but as I remember there was not a lot of
smokers and I think the smoking groups
were pretty equal
and then you follow them for six months
so at six months the group on the
plant-based diet had a dramatic drop in
their PSA
whereas the group not on the plant-based
diet had an actual increase in their PSA
and more of them had to go towards
conventional therapy but then he took
that one one step further he took the
serum their blood serum he took prostate
cancer cells and put them in a dish drip
the blood serum of the plant-based eater
versus just the regular person and the
plant-based eaters their serum was eight
times more effective at killing pancreas
cell a killing prostate cancer cells so
there's something in the serum then he
took it a step further he took their
hormone their um not their hormones
their chromosomes and he worked with a
Nobel Prize winner who had studied
what's called telomeres telomeres are
like the caps on chromosomes think of
them as like like the cap of a on the
end of your shoelace to prevent the
shoelace from unraveling and it has been
shown that the longer the telomere
the less likely you are to get genetic
damage and in fact they found that the
plant-based eating group had a longer
telomere they lengthened their telomere
over time that's that's amazing I think
telomere research is the next thing you
know how like it's all about like the
gut biome right yeah I think that's I
think I think it's teal because the it's
when you start looking into that it's
pretty fascinating uh the link between
um you know sort of extending telomere
length and and cell life longevity and
aging it's quite fast it's amazing so so
why wasn't the Nightly News like
groundbreaking study coming out you know
of University of California San
Francisco it just it kind of comes out
and goes away why do you think that is
I think it goes back to this you know
we're telling people they need to change
their lifestyle people don't want to
change their lifestyle and the industry
is providing them all kinds of reasons
to believe that whatever the study is uh
it is just a side you know study that
really isn't anything to be worried
about well it's a lot easier to get
people to pay attention to something
that affirms that there is good news
about your bad habits of course you know
that's a big study of butter and saying
butter is good for you and everybody's
so excited which is so bizarre because
we are the most unhealthy country in the
world right we have the highest obesity
highest diabetes highest cancer one of
the lowest longevity rates and yet we
try we eat more protein than any other
country in the world yet we want to eat
more protein and I keep asking my
patients how's it working for you you
know oh I've been on this protein diet
I've been on that protein diet and I'm
like well you got to stop eating that
much protein like what do you mean yeah
I gotta eat protein how's it working for
you it's not working it's not working
for the country why aren't we looking at
the countries that are the healthiest
and what they're doing and there was a
great project done
um in North Korea where they really did
an excellent job in cardiac morbidity
and mortality by getting people to stop
eating butter
that was their big project is getting
people to stop eating butter and here we
are saying butter is good for you it's
just it blows my mind well you look at
the statistics and how unhealthy we are
uh and then you compare that to our
obsession with health because there's no
other country that's also as as obsessed
with weight loss and health as we are
and then when you study these cultures
that have the you know the longest
incidence of longevity and are the most
disease free and they don't I don't
think they really think about health and
dieting and you know they're not going
to the gym right they're not taking
supplements yeah so it's it's this weird
mashup of of being unhealthy and yet
being obsessed with health at the same
time but pursuing a track that is not
solving the problem right right and and
sometimes I just feel like I'm in the
Twilight Zone with it it's like people
just think about it it's just so obvious
but um so on that note like a couple
things I mean the first thing is I'm
sure that
people come up to you all the time and
say you know when you start when you
start spouting your Garth Davis
plant-based diatribe you know they go
well listen Garth don't you know that
The China Study was debunked everybody
knows that it was debunked I mean what
is your response to that
you know I never mentioned The China
Study anywhere in any of my talks it's
kind of older data and Colin did a lot
of study on rats and I'm not a big fan
of rat studies so it's just you know I
don't I don't have certainly not been
debunked by anybody I mean the big thing
was that Denise minger
debunked him and she put up a uh a rant
where she took some of his raw data and
did what we talked about earlier did a
univariate analysis said look at this
group they're eating more wheat
and they have more heart disease and but
what she didn't do is look at the fact
that they were also eating more meat I
mean it's she didn't she didn't do a
good scientific study now interestingly
so she's sort of guilty of what she was
accusing him of doing oh yeah absolutely
and that happens all the time a lot of
these paleo people and in high protein
people and everything like that they
they will criticize any study unless
it's their study uh like you know
epidemiology is terrible but if you come
out with epidemiology study that says
meat is good all of a sudden that's the
greatest study that ever lived so yeah
we see that a lot from them now
interesting Denise has come out recently
saying you know what vegan diet might
actually be the right diet what she's
come down to is now that there's two
extremes that seem to work either an
extreme high fat high protein low carb
diet or an extreme vegan diet and
everything in the middle is is wrong
well what about that what about let's
talk about the the extreme you know high
fat high protein low carb diet because
that is you know that is of you know
that is in Vogue right now it's in Vogue
a lot of the studies were coming come
out from a guy named Nokes who was
studying this in athletes the idea was
if I could get an athlete on a bike for
a long distance and not needing any food
during that time just using fat fat
adopted fat adapted that that would uh
that that would be a superior situation
fact of the matter is notes was
successful you can do that you can fat
adapt and then you can go on a long bike
ride using your fat does that correlate
to more weight loss than any of the
other diets no does it correlate to
better times for The Athlete nope
um and so it it really didn't amount to
anything then to say yes you can fat it
up but it's fatter that better not
necessarily now the problem has come
where you've taken data on
on well-trained athletes and try to
apply it to the population as a whole
and the problem comes several ways so
people here
um oh I lost a weight on a high protein
diet now the reason people lose weight
on a high protein diet is they go into
ketosis
what happens is they basically deplete
their body of glycogen glycogen is the
storage of carbs and the muscles
the muscles are stored with water so you
definitely lose water and the ketones
that are formed make you Diaries more so
you know you pee off some water until
you lose weight but every study done on
these high protein diets is that you
will lose weight for a while then you'll
slowly start to gain it back
what happens is people then think okay
on this extreme diet people lost weight
with protein so it must be the protein
if I eat it even not in an extreme
situation it's going to make me lose
weight and that's nonsense I I can't
tell you there are so many studies I got
tired reading it that if you take a
person and you put them on a 1800
calorie diet
it doesn't matter how much protein
they've done studies where they've done
really high protein and low protein and
menial protein and it doesn't matter the
macronutrient combination does not
affect the weight loss so long as you're
eating 1800 there was a professor out of
Kentucky who ate nothing but twinkies
and Oreos and junk food but he kept his
weight his calories under 1800 he lost
weight he lost uh his LDL cholesterol
went down even though he's eating
twinkies and the funny thing is as soon
as he started eating meat it all came
back on interesting because he didn't
eat any meat during that time he was
just eating he ate one salad a day and a
junk food the rest of the time so
macronutrient combinations everyone's
counting macros that's the big thing now
Kenny macros it makes no
difference in weight loss the calorie
count does now here's the thing
the calorie count is so important but
people do a terrible job counting
calories because they just totally mess
up how many calories are in fat I mean
they oil up their pan you know Pam
cooking spray it says low-fat cooking
yeah what says like zero grams of fat on
the front because you'd have to have a
microgram if you know it's a wonderful
that's a surgeon the serving sizes one
fourth of a second of a spray but people
are just spraying it all in there and
you go out to eat and you get a calorie
count on the food that you're eating but
that doesn't count the grease that's on
the so I find people do a really bad job
um calorie counting but but here's the
thing when you eat meat let's go away
from the weight loss because that's all
anybody seems to care about weight loss
and muscles this is no one seems to
really care about the heart disease
until they have it
um but every time you eat meat a few
things happen you put acid into your
body because meat is heavy in amino
acids and those acids that have sulfa
definitely increase the acid content in
the body now your body has to buffer
that acid and in buffering the acid
that's where you get a lot of problems
so it steals a lot of calcium from
muscles so I think a lot of the problems
that with the with the bodybuilding
population is I think think they're
asking the wrong question they're
looking at how much protein do I need to
eat to gain muscle instead they should
be asking what do I need to eat to
maintain muscle
the second thing you're doing is you're
eating heterocyclic amines which are
known carcinogens but every time you
cook a steak and that burned muscle
turns into a chemical that can cause
cancer you're developing and nitroso
compounds another carcinogen you are
getting Advanced glycolated end products
I mean I could go on and on the list
goes on and on of all these terrible
toxins and stuff that you're putting in
your body every time you eat a steak
um and we have all this data that you
know long term it's not good for you so
I just don't understand you know why if
it's not going to help you lose weight
and if it's not going to help you live
longer why people are doing and the
answer is the industry is out there in
there they'll sell you those protein
shakes they sell those protein shakes I
have protein shakes in my office simply
I tell my patients not to drink them
except we need them around the time of
surgery
they sell that protein shake to lose
weight it's the exact same product
that's being sold for other people to
get bodybuilders to gain weight yeah
yeah so exact same product interesting
uh well isn't that they're on the Slow
Carb Diet I think it's the idea is that
you're supposed to start your day with a
you know 25 grams of protein and a shake
and that somehow this has sets you up
for you know I don't know better
metabolism throughout the day that will
lead to weight loss right and there are
some data that do show some good Society
but the problem with the data is they're
never they're always comparing shake to
shake so they're taking a shake and
they're varying the carbohydrate the
protein and then testing it and see
who's hunger later hungry or later the
plant-based diet wins because of fiber
that's what is the site associating
factor and so I don't really care if a
low-fat high carb Shake makes you
hungrier if it doesn't have fiber in it
because that's not what I'm eating and
not what I'm telling my patients to eat
they did a really good study where they
had people sit down and eat different
meals and then check how hungry they
were at the next meal in the meal after
and the most satiating food you could
possibly eat was a potato
interesting yeah so I think in one of
your I think it was in your talk that I
saw recently you said something like uh
you know only three percent of the
population is protein deficient and but
oh I would say lesson but like but like
97 of the population is fiber deficient
and what we should be talking about is
fiber and not protein right right when
you look at they came out the new and
Haynes data and what do we actually eat
in this country no one's protein
deficient you gotta understand the RDA
well a protein deficiency would be
starvation it would be like core sugars
yeah exactly you'd have to you would
have to not be eating you'd have to be
eating less than a thousand calories to
probably get it
um and so we just don't see that
um so the RDA when they set up their
recommendation for protein requirements
they based it on some nitrogen balance
studies and all this kind of stuff and
they came up with a figure
like for men 56 grams and for women 44
grams or 42 grams and that figure is
actually an optimal amount it's not a
minimal amount I think people think
that's the lowest amount that I should
get it's actually the optimal amount
based on those studies probably you
would do fine with 30 grams of protein
but they just want to make sure that
everybody was covered
now we eat 70 to 100 sometimes 130 grams
of protein a day so we're way over the
optimal amount we're way in excess I
mean all these studies where they've
gone and interview people the one thing
everyone's looking for is even more
protein to make it's crazy yet we eat
unbelievably low amounts of fiber and
there there are not a lot of good
studies that show that there's long-term
health and eating a lot of protein
there's tons of good studies tons and
tons showing eating a lot of fiber is
good for you long term and we are
unbelievable we are in a massive deficit
of fiber and yet no one's talking about
that well don't you know that we we
shouldn't be eating fruit that this is
terrible yeah and that really makes me
wanted to jump off uh sugar is a sugar
yeah sugars is sugars is ridiculous a
sugar or sugar is not true if a sugar is
combined with fiber
um that fiber makes sugar into a slow
release pill
what people don't understand it is
almost impossible
and this is true of sugar too it's
almost impossible for a sugar for a carb
to return to fat
it's called the novo lipogenesis and
your body will not turn sugar or carbs
to fat until you've completely saturated
all the glycogen in your body which is
about 1 500 grams of glycogen and then
if you once you've saturated glycogen
it'll still give you
some leeway where you eat more carbs
it's going to try to burn them more it
actually UPS the metabolism to try to
burn them people say that protein have
some metabolism carbs donut the regular
intake but if you overeat carbs it
actually helps your metabolism to try to
burn them and so it's very difficult to
turn carbs to Fat now
simple sugars will make you hungry
because it'll make your blood sugar rise
and then drop and then you're going to
want more sugar and you get these sweets
Cravings Etc et cetera so I definitely
don't tell people to eat sugar but for
the love of God eat fruit it's just it's
made that we are fruit eaters everything
about our body about our anatomy you
look at comparative science yeah I was
watching Naked and Afraid you ever watch
Naked and Afraid oh this is a great show
where they drop people off naked in the
middle of the Wilderness and they almost
die and then they pick them up 21 days
later but I'm watching them and there's
this one scene where this lady's like
just she's just dying and she's the
whole every show they're talking about
how they need to get protein like we
need to get some protein I need to get
protein now I'm going to die and yeah
they do need to probably get some
protein because they're eating zero
calories but um in this one scene this
monkey's kind of just sitting down
eating a branch eating some leaves
looking at them just like oh you idiots
and I'm thinking about myself eat what
the monkey's eating because we are made
to eat what the monkey's eating I would
Follow That Monkey around and eat that
monkey's food uh yeah but don't
volunteer me I don't sure but but the
point being we are perfectly created to
eat fruit we could live long healthy
lives just eating fruit you and I both
know fruititarians who eat the majority
of their calories for fruit and they're
unbelievably healthy people
yeah interesting I mean as a marathoner
and an Iron Man athlete yourself uh is
there any argument to be made that
um when you're training really hard if
you want to get as strong as possible if
you want to build and lean you know
muscle mass Etc that you should eat
protein in excess of your RDA
hey that's a tough question and in my
book I kind of go into this a bit it's
so much harder to study this than it is
the other stuff
um
and there there's good data but then
every time I see a good paper it's
always industry sponsored and I've
talked with the scientists they're like
look we couldn't get anything done if
the industry doesn't sponsors it doesn't
mean that it's good science
if you're just an average person no so
you know and everyone thinks they're
more than an average person but no one's
doing the workouts then we know it takes
to be in that above average field so for
them absolutely not now
um for real athletes there has been some
increased uh they look at muscle protein
synthesis and there is some increased
muscle protein synthesis with about 20
grams of protein after
um a workout the studies are hard to
look at because there's many confounding
factors they they have people start
they're fasted when they do their
workout so they're already you know
going on the deficient then they get the
protein so there's other argument
studies that argue you know
um it doesn't matter when you eat the
protein as long as you have protein all
day long
I would say probably a modest increase
in protein would be fine but plant-based
protein is fine I personally never count
ever never count I never think to myself
I need to get protein I'll make a
post-workout Shake where I will throw in
some hemp seeds and I'll get some
protein there I eat nuts during the day
I'll get protein there I eat a lot of
beans
and I'm only getting stronger and faster
I mean every year I just seem to be
growing so for me I it doesn't seem to
be effect in the you know vegan
bodybuilding world I've interviewed a
bunch of people a lot of them say they
don't do extra protein they do the same
thing I do uh you know at the end of a
workout they'll go and eat a meal with
beans in it which to me is the healthy
thing to do but I I don't know I can't
vouch for the truth you know and I don't
know if they're doing steroids or
anything like that they look great yeah
interesting I mean is there an argument
to be made that uh
that the protein from animal flesh is
qualitatively different from the protein
from plants in other words is an amino
acid an amino acid irrespective of where
it comes from or is the Matrix in which
which it's delivered to your body does
that make a difference in terms in terms
of how you metabolize it the
bioavailability and all of that
yeah you know um you bring up a good
point but um the studies that have shown
that bioavailability of plant-based
proteins is excellent the problem is
more like the um
uh the actual amino acid array in each
protein so meat-based proteins are a
little bit I hate the term complete
because that makes people think that
they're better but they've got higher of
certain proteins
um like for instance plant-based
proteins are much higher in glutamic
acid now glutamic acid is fantastic for
lowering blood pressure which might be
part of the reason plants are so good
with lung pressure
meat-based proteins are higher in Branch
chain amino acids now if you're a
bodybuilder this is good for several
reasons it increases igf-1 igf-1 is a
growth hormone so it's a growth hormone
you're going to grow your muscles
number two
um
there are definitely things like leucine
definitely stimulate muscle protein
synthesis and so if your bodybuilder you
want to stimulate muscle protein
synthesis but here's the catch we know
from aging studies and from cancer
studies that having a high igf-1 and
high leucine actually leads to premature
aging
and cellular death and cancer
so what I'm seeing from these
bodybuilding protocols that may in fact
make a bodybuilder have more muscle may
make them unhealthier in the long term I
mean it's impossible to do a good study
on it but if you look at old
bodybuilders they all have a scar down
the middle of their chest they've all
had heart surgery now is that the high
protein diets or is it the steroids you
know I can't differentiate that and tell
you that right but it's that argument of
uh the difference between a
performance-oriented diet like a
short-term performance-oriented diet
versus long-term longevity maximum
Wellness diet yeah I mean it's hard to
say I mean look at look at Scott jurik
look at
um
Dave Scott when he was competing at his
Peak I mean these athletes were the top
of their game and they were eating
plant-based diets and not concentrating
on protein and I find a lot of these
there's more and more athletes coming
out of the Woodworks now that are
following a plant-based diet and say
that they feel better than ever now like
I told you before they obviously have
less acid in their body so they're not
trying to buffer the acid with calcium
from the muscle and so maybe you do a
study that look at muscle protein
synthesis and there's a slight Advantage
if you're getting more protein but what
we're not studying is what's muscle
breakdown over the long term and I think
that's you know a lot of these um
bodybuilders that you talk to that are
vegan bodybuilders every year they seem
to be consistently big they don't seem
to go through these fluxes that other
people go to but this is a field that is
wrought with yeah I could tell you very
confidently about the cancer and the
longevity I can't tell you that
confidently about building muscle and
performance well I noticed on your
Facebook page you shared that picture of
that dude who was like the butcher yeah
yeah yeah and the dude is Fraser
absolutely ripped
he's a great guy because he is totally
changed his whole life like this guy
just like a light bulb went on he used
to be a butcher now he gained his muscle
back when he was a meat eater but he's
honed it now that he's a plant-based
eater swears he doesn't do steroids
everybody in my thing is steroid steroid
steroid I've never tested him so I can't
test I would say absolutely he doesn't
because he swears he doesn't but after
Lance Armstrong I've given up swearing
for other people but my point on that
picture was not
um steroids are how he looks or anything
which is his story of transformation how
great he feels now interesting yeah I
want to get back to this idea of fat
adaptation and ketosis and the like and
you know as an endurance athlete
becoming fat adapted that's something
that's very interesting the more fat
adapted I can become the longer I can go
without relying on nutrition the more
efficient I am in whether it's cycling
or swimming or running or what have you
and I've worked on my fat adaptation
predominantly through training protocols
that focus on you know enhancing my
aerobic Zone capacity by training Yeah
by training in that zone and it's in my
experience and it's completely anecdotal
has been that I'm able to do that
through how I train it's less about you
know it's less about the diet aspect of
it than it is what what does my training
look like so you know I'm sure that that
you know when you go out and you do
those fasted workouts that it has some
impact on that but it but if I do that
then I pay for it the next day or the
day after like I can't train every
single day consistently if I'm depriving
my body of nutrients when I go out to
train so when I'm looking at like the
course of a season
um you know I'm focusing on that Z2 work
which really allows me to really enhance
my ability that go all day speed which
is really fat adaptation but I'm just
doing it through the training as opposed
to trying to achieve that through what
I'm putting in my mouth yeah I mean
there's certainly data to say that if
you're going at zone two you are burning
fat if you do it on a fasted State
you're gonna you know start fat adapting
but the literature has been really weak
on on any kind of performance advantage
to that and so it may be and it's
certainly weak on everyone's like oh I
want to burn fat thinking that they're
going to have a six-pack abs by doing
that that doesn't tend to turn out to be
the case there's a there's multiple
variables we got to think about and that
is what about the acid load you're
taking in and how does that affect your
performance so while you're burning your
fat you're also got a lot of acid in
your body and that might be detrimental
you're missing out on the phytonutrients
and nutrients and things that you would
typically be eating in a high carb diet
which may be affecting your performance
and the one thing that you will always
hear from plant-based athletes that I
think you really mess up when you start
trying to do fat adaption is is
recovered it just seems that that high
fruit you know smoothie you make after
that workout really helps you recover
for the next day's workout and so I just
I I I I see the science and the fat
adaptation but I don't see the benefit
interesting I I was uh on the Joe Rogan
podcast recently and the question the
topic came up about ketosis and I made I
don't know exactly what I said but I
said something like you know I'm just
not I'm not sure that it's really the
healthiest thing to do for you long term
like it's sort of a critical State I
mean it's sort of a um an emergency
State it's an emergency your body right
and I didn't go really much further
beyond that and then I got beat up for
not knowing what I was talking about and
misunderstanding what ketos is Joe Rogan
teacher no he didn't but sort of the
comments and the feedback that kind of
that swirled around that as a result of
that like you know he was cool we didn't
we didn't really get into some huge
debate about it
so you know don't educate me about what
ketosis is like am I was I
mischaracterizing it or what is your
understanding of what it means to be in
ketosis because I feel like there's this
movement whereby uh you know ketosis has
become this aspirational lifestyle for
people that they're always trying to be
in ketosis that on some level this the
argument is made that this is a natural
state of man and we should be you know
trying to be in this state and that we
can and and can be health healthy doing
this yeah
and that is with zero evidence
whatsoever I mean all the ketosis
studies are so short-term they're
ridiculous I mean really short term uh
secondly it is it is an emergency state
for our bodies to live in we don't want
to be in ketosis
um our bodies Thrive I mean if you look
at the Krebs cycle which is the cycle
that generates energy
the input is glucose
that's the input now
there are other places where we could
input in emergency situations and that's
where the ketones come in from but our
primary
um
our primary feel for our body comes from
glucose and certainly from our brain so
our body can that's I made that point
too and was told that I didn't know what
I was talking about no it's absolutely
true the brain actually can't live off
our fat but it can live off um not only
glucose now um
the ketones do cross the blood-brain
barrier so that it can get some food
through the ketones but when you're in
serious ketosis you're not a happy
camper the side effects are huge nausea
vomiting
um and uh terrible breath
um and uh and just constipation like
crazy and Atkins had to deal with all
this with his patients so he had all
kinds of supplements and stuff to give
them in these situations
um really bad uric acid Stones
so gout would flare a lot I see I've had
so many patients come to me with gout
when they're on an Atkins diet and
kidney stones like crazy kidney stones
it's just not a natural weight our
bodies not very good at handling acid
not like a carnivore so carnivore is
perfectly created you could put a a lion
on a ketotic diet and they'd be fine but
um but they don't need the fiber they've
got a short intestinal tract they don't
need Vitamin C they don't need any of
these things but um
a plant-based eater like we're designed
to be like a Fruitvale like a monkey and
is meant to be eating fruits and that's
what our mouth that's what I digestive
check we have amylase in our saliva you
go on and on and on we're made to be
eating these foods that are primary
uh to make us live a healthy life the
ketosis is an emergency situation should
there be a famine or a freeze and we
can't get our food but when foods are
plenty we're eating fruit that's what
we're supposed to be doing when you look
at the fruitarians like whether it's
somebody like fully raw Christina who's
a mutual friend of ours or Michael
arnstein or some of these people out
there that that you know I know these
people they're like vibrating Health
they have like their skin looks amazing
they have positive energy you know they
look you in the eye they're very present
there's something about that lifestyle
that seems to really agree with the
people that adapt it
and they become so passionate about it
it's almost you know it's like they're
just exuding enthusiasm for this
lifestyle but what is like you know I've
never been a fruitarian I've never gone
that far down you know down the road
that way I mean what is your opinion on
kind of the long-term impacts of of
eating that way yeah there's do you
suggest that for your patients or I
don't suggest it I don't suggest it
because you know I don't suggest
anything where I don't have good data to
support it my gut feeling is it's very
healthy but I I just don't have data
supportive people where's the protein
come from there's amino acids and fruit
and the other thing you got to
understand is our body recycles our
amino acids very effectively so we break
down our protein into amino acids and
then retake them up and reuse them again
so we have a built-in amino acid store
and the ones that I've met are just you
know top of the sports amino acid they
don't care about they don't read they're
never taken think about it they don't do
anything they don't they're just eating
their bananas and doing great and so um
I think there's something real to it I
don't know that I'm you know I need more
science before I would give it to my
patients but I told Christina I'm
willing to give it a shot so she's going
to put me on her uh oh you're going to
do it I'm going to do her raw 21 day
diet and it's weird for me because I say
I don't ever count protein or think
about protein but I eat a lot of beans I
love beans beans and rice are like my
go-to meal and I think someone who's
real I really you know all the gurus
that have come out on plant-based
dieting I think I've probably tend to
rewards more towards McDougall in a
starch-based diet I really feel like we
are star cheaters and and do very well
on starch diets and that's what I really
can get my patients to do
um
but I could see the benefit with the um
with the raw food diet I just I'd like
to prove it to myself and get them more
more studies before I did it with
patients interesting so let's talk about
the book man how close are you to being
it's it is done it's done yeah that was
a uh I don't ever do it again it's a lot
of work oh my God am I um I mean you
just lived in the research how many
years have you been working on it three
years uh-huh yeah is it is it called
what's it called a protein method it's
called a proteinaholic the protein
session with protein how it's killing
this yeah my general point like I don't
want to get into reduction of scientists
I don't want to be a fear Monger
actually I probably should be a fear
Monger because we're dying I I want to
be a fear Monger because we're the most
unhealthy people in the world and when
no one fears their double cheeseburger
but um but yeah I mean I started this
you know years ago I was talking with
the my editor at Harper one Gideon Weil
and he's like what is the central
problem out there and he was he was
great with me because I just had this
General view of people are eating like
crap that's you know they're not eating
enough uh fruit vegetables and nuts
beans and seeds yeah he's like that's
too General why aren't they eating that
and it kind of jailed down I was like
you know what I just started getting
this view of every patient that comes in
my office and I go over their diet what
diets have you done before why doesn't
Atkins I've done South Beach I've done
Zone currently on Atkins right now
so you believe in high protein diets yes
then why are you sitting in my office
you know and so that's when he really
got me thinking man maybe it's the
protein it's this idea and I hate this
reduction of science I really do but the
only way I'm going to fight the
reduction of science is is to become a
productionist myself and prove it wrong
and so I did research I mean I think
there's a thousand papers and referenced
in the Articles and I really go into
really good depth tying them all
together so it's not like oh here's one
PubMed article that says this it's like
let's look at all these together let's
look at the good and the bad and uh show
you that this desire to get huge amounts
of protein is completely unnecessary and
the carbs are certainly not bad for you
so that's the basic thesis of the book
basic thesis yeah right and so do you
have case studies throughout that or is
it like your own experience or is it
just is it very research based or it's a
very I start out with kind of my story
you know talking a lot about what we've
just talked here about like right let's
recap that again if somebody's listening
to this and they haven't gone back and
listened to the first time that we chat
about it yeah I mean I was you know here
I was you know go to medical school
study everything you could ever want to
know about a cell but never once studied
nutrition get into residency start
developing a belly go on the Atkins diet
and get sick think I forget it I'm just
going to be a busy Surgeon get into
practice and you know I'm seeing people
with cancer and and
diabetes and heart disease and I'm
treating this obesity and I'm looking at
everybody's diet plan and everybody's
eating the same damn thing and that's
exactly what I'm eating you know eggs
for breakfast Subway sandwich for lunch
chicken for dinner
hamburgers here and there
and um and I stop and think God I'm
operating on people but I'm not telling
them what to eat in fact I wrote a book
that said eat high protein and
everyone's coming in you know well I
followed your advice on any high protein
I'm gaining back weight
and so I started to really think gosh
this is bad and then I got my life
insurance policy because when I was
having a kid and my cholesterol was Sky
High my liver function tests were high I
was hypertensive and they denied me for
my life insurance policy and then of
course my friend a medical doctor was
like oh no problem we'll put you on
Lipitor we'll put you on a beta Block
open but I knew you know I know what
happens you get worse and worse and
worse you're gonna have a heart attack
at 50 60. and so I said there's got to
be a different way and then that's when
I really started studying these other
cultures and how it works and the more I
study the more research I said my
patients could benefit this not just me
the more I started incorporating my
patients and you know totally changed my
practice and now I've got you know the
healthiest patients and makes me a busy
doctor yeah you have you're you're super
active on Facebook you write these long
articles and rants yeah you know and you
share your your patients success stories
and there's some pretty amazing like
before and after pictures and and and
anecdotes about some of the people that
have passed through your practice yeah
yeah they're great I mean I have some
patients that it's just been diet now
you know I'm known for the surgery that
my patients are not your typical
patients you know they come in 400
pounds you know this is these are Big
patients so we do do surgery but we I've
changed the Paradigm where there's diet
instruction from the get-go some of the
people decide not to do surgery those
that do surgery definitely go and I
don't really tell vegetarian or vegan I
just say I want you more plant-based
turn don't do what Americans do don't
let Chicken be the star of the plate
actually flip the plate around and I
give them we do cooking classes we do
you know a lot of nutrition which my
colleagues are not doing and that has
made my surgery patients so successful
because you're losing money
yeah well those ones I operate on but
there are some that I lose money and I
saw a lady the other day she's you know
her body mass since she's 36 she barely
qualifies for surgery she said listen I
will pay you cash to do it and I said
listen I went over her diet plan I was
like you can lose this weight easily
but I'm eating a lot of protein that's
the problem you know change the protein
I don't know if you saw hey I had a
great story the other day about a lady
comes in she wants
um she's from Ghana when she wants
surgery
and she's been living in the United
States for 10 years and at that time
she's gotten really heavy and she's very
educated she's an engineer and she's
doing everything she comes in she's on
weight loss pills and she's currently on
Atkins she's done Atkins several times
she's done South Beach she's done
um zoned on all these diets and so we're
going over her diet plan what do you eat
for breakfast eggs
what do you eat for lunch chicken I just
have a chicken breast what do you eat
for dinner and it's going on I'm like
okay so
you obviously believe in all this
protein and everything why do you think
it's failing what's not working she goes
well I'm from Ghana and I've got friends
from Ghana and they come over and we
have a typical Ghana meal
and I think that's what making me gain
weight because it's too many carbs I'm
like what is your Ghana meal she's like
oh it's really bad it's like potatoes
and sweet potatoes and we do sweet
potato stew and we use uh cassava and
all this stuff and I'm like that's the
best meal you've had all day and I said
okay well do you ever go to goddess she
goes yes I was like okay how many people
are overweight in Ghana oh nobody I'm
the biggest person when I'm there by far
all right and when you're there what do
you eat why I eat the food that my
family eats there and well you know now
that you've mentioned it I lose weight
every time I go there I'm like you see
my point but it's sometimes so people
are just so addicted to this idea that
protein is what makes you lose weight
and so they're stuffing themselves
filled with food that we know does not
make you lose we're being inundated with
this message everywhere we turn I mean I
love when you go to these conferences
and you speak at these conferences you
take pictures of what the breakfast is
and you know kind of like the
nutritional recommendations that are
being proposed by some of the doctors
with whom you share with Podium yeah I
mean I was at the American Society of
bariatric medicine this is a society
that is it's the medical doctor is
dealing with weight
again you go to these meetings not a lot
of talk about diet everything's high
protein it's sponsored by Atkins
the chairperson of the committee is from
duke
um Eric Westerman
and he gets money from Atkins and he
runs these high protein diets and he put
up his typical day's diet for the
patients and it was I saw that thing and
I wanted to run up on stage and attack
him because I can't imagine telling a
patient to eat
cheeseburgers and and um
his diet I put it on my Facebook was
just almost anything bad you could
possibly think of it was like his diet
that he recommends for his patients is
the diet my patients come in on uh you
know at 400 pounds and I just think it
is unbelievable disservice what he's
getting is a quick weight loss because
these people are going into ketosis but
they always put it back on they always
land back up in my office
that's sad so if you like if you could
leave uh the audience with like a couple
things that they could just think about
that might be uh contrary to what they
might imagine about diet or a couple
things that they could just Implement
into their life to start to make a shift
yeah you know what what are some of
those things well it was a great study
recently where they showed that if you
just tell people to eat 35 grams of
fiber a day and don't give them anything
else more complicated don't weigh this
don't weigh that just eat 35 grams of
fiber a day people get really good
weight loss people that are eating tons
of fiber don't really get sick they
don't get sick
they they I mean you know because it's
not just the fiber it's what the fiber
is you know there's no fiber in the
animal products there's only fiber in
the plant right but if you forget just
forget about protein and let's shift all
of that Focus that you had on protein
and put it on fiber and then see what
would happen yeah my message would be
it's almost impossible not to get enough
protein no matter what you're eating
that's number one number two eating more
protein will make you sick eventually
um and number three eating more plants
is really like finding a fountain of
youth
um it makes you it's not just because
people say oh I don't care if I live you
know 10 years longer if you know I have
to eat that crap the food's delicious
it's just your whole taste buds change
that's the thing I think people miss or
don't get they don't and they can't
imagine that they'll actually get to a
place where they will desire or crave
healthy foods you know I have patients
say to me I wish I had your willpower to
me it's not willpower it's not willpower
for me to eat a kale salad my crave a
kale salad but I used to crave a double
cheeseburger and you could change that I
could talk about how I change that with
patients but you could change this
thought process and you can change your
taste and everybody who goes through it
I get this you know blessing you know
all these people online yakking about
this and that and they've never treated
a patient I get to sit across from a
patient actually see these changes and
the changes are amazing the way people
feel the way they look what they're
doing in their life it's it's really
rewarding and when I think about how
many people in this world could benefit
if we just got rid of this idea of
protein and went to the idea of you know
Whole Foods fruits vegetables beans it
would really change the health of the
country the health of the environment
and uh and and have so many other
benefits out there where do you come
down on grains I mean you're kind of a
McDougall guy I love grass um you know
but there's this idea that uh you know
today's wheat is not your grandmother's
wheat it's highly hybridized you know
most wheat is stripped of its
nutritional value and higher in gluten
than it ever has been and we're seeing
allergies and all kinds of things so and
you have the wheat belly and the green
brain books out there that are
influencing a lot of people yeah you
know the wheat Billy I mean
that book there's just no the science is
so bad in those books it's just I and of
course the lay person doesn't know how
to read the science and understand that
that there's something being put over on
them
um they did a great study recently
because everybody's
such a placebo effect everyone now is so
affected by grain they were eating it 10
years ago without a complaint about it
but now everybody's got um gluten
sensitivity so they took a group of
people
and three they put them in three groups
one they were all going to give give
them the food okay they're all getting
food given to them one group is going to
be they're all told you don't know what
your gluten levels this this may you may
be getting a low gluten you may be
getting a high glute but you're all
Gluten Sensitive so the one group gets a
really high gluten level another gets a
medium gluten level one group gets no
gluten level absolutely no difference in
the symptoms the low gluten group has
the exact same symptom as high glue
they're like oh my God I feel terrible
this glue so are you saying that gluten
is not a thing like gluten's not the
gluten sensitivity is imagined
absolutely imagine really just imagine
now what might I mean I can tell you
that if I eat like a lot of processed
wheat like bread or whatever that I I
feel like my my the skin around my eyes
in Flames like there's a whole thing
that happens there's a feel lousy I get
tired there's a sensitivity to fodmaps
you know fodmaps are fructo oligo
polysaccharides
um a lot of the times when people are
having these symptoms to different foods
it's our gut bacteria in a way our gut
bacteria
interplays with those
and and I think that is a lot more to do
with it so these people that so all
three groups were having symptoms now
were those symptoms faking in their head
maybe maybe not maybe what they're
reacting to is not the gluten but the
fact that these grains have
fodmaps these different um
oligosaccharides which are certain
carbohydrates that their body just their
their
bacteria just can't handle and that
might be a big part of the problem um
but people that have okay I get inflamed
when I eat wheat if I take you to a lab
and then draw your blood and look for
all the factors that show inflammation
zero will come out positive there will
be no inflammation
unless you have spru celiac disease you
actually have Celiac that's a different
story then I will that's the thing about
this gluten and sensitivity
oh this gluten sensitivity that's out
there right now everybody thinks they're
an inflammation but it doesn't show up
in any of their lab there's no lab value
for gluten sensitivity it's a
symptomatology without any clinical
findings in it and it may not be the
gluten now the it would be fine to just
drop the grains
except that the grains are fantastic for
you so if you look at the long-term
studies grains are unbelievably good for
diabetes they're unbelievably good for
heart disease and they're a big source
of our fiber as well as a lot of the B
vitamins so what we're doing is taking
away this you know group of food that's
actually extremely good for you there's
even studies that show that grain is
good for your brain but when we're
talking about grains I mean you know
we're not talking about eating you know
Triscuit crackers no no that's processed
I mean there's a there's a difference
between eating you know uh you know a
processed past you know grain-based
pasta and maybe you know a really like
an heirloom Millet or something like
that those are qualitatively very
different right because the processing
like just take oatmeal for instance
because they've done a lot of studies on
oatmeal or you take a steel cut a rolled
oat or if you take a quick oat or an
instant oat what they're doing is
basically shucking off more of the germ
fiber so that it Cooks easier and it
Cooks quicker but the problem is then
you eat like let's you take that instant
oatmeal you eat it you get a big blood
sugar surge there's a big blood sugar
drop and you're hungrier again sooner
because there's less fiber in it
um but if you take the whole o and even
if there's the same amount of fiber in
it the whole oat takes longer to break
down and digest you're not going to get
this blood sugar surge you'll have a
longer slower blood sugar release which
provides energy without problems so yeah
I mean I think most of the the problems
with with wheat are in general probably
have to do with our gut microbiome
the way we process it how does GMO fit
in that I don't know there may be
something with GMO in that but boy that
that research is hard to go through
because industry is all over it I mean
when somebody says what should I think
about GMOs whether you how do you
respond to that generally I generally
respond that I would be careful my
general thought is
they say it's good for you they haven't
done the studies to show that it's good
for you they just haven't and it would
take a lot of studies and it'd be a
difficult study but my general question
is why GMO I mean why would you why
would you want something that you know
where they're messing with the genetic
structure of the food the other thing
that bothers me about GMOs is not even
the GMO it's the result of having a GMO
product which is you're growing a huge
monocultural crop
that huge monocultural crop is terrible
for the environment the soil is devoid
of nutrient uh and so that's just not
the food I want I want to put in my body
I I think we're going to find out that
GMO is is extremely bad for you but I
you know I can't I don't have the
science behind it that I do with saying
that meat causes diabetes
yeah caution yeah caution for sure yeah
I mean it's not just I mean when you're
dealing there's all different kinds of
GMOs too you know like it's not one
thing but if you're dealing with you
know sort of a strain of food that has
been bred to be pestilent resistant and
deal well with glycipate that means that
it's Laden with all sorts of chemicals
on top of it that are in the soil and
absorbed into the roots and and all of
that so there's more there's more going
on right and there was a very biased
study that was done by Stanford looking
at um
at Organics versus inorganics and they
said that there's no difference in the
nutrient level and there's been other
studies that said oh they didn't do it
right there are differences but this
very you know this group that was
getting money from biotech and stuff did
say without a doubt the GMO group had
higher pesticides so why do you want to
eat pesticide these people are like oh
we gotta have GMOs I don't understand it
um I don't want pesticides in my food I
mean glyphosphate has just been labeled
as a carcinogen and this is not just the
tip of the ice cap of what's going on I
mean you know the FDA is supposed to do
trials anytime there or the USDA is
supposed to do trials I'm sorry FDA is
supposed to do trials anytime a new
product comes out like that's a GMO to
make sure it's safe well they had a GMO
Alfalfa come out and the FDA just said
now let's go ahead and use it and there
weren't any testing done so the union of
concerned scientists the committee
concerned scientists took this up and
they they fought a battle and it went
all the way up to Supreme Court and
Supreme Court said yeah the FDA could do
whatever they want
the head of the FDA that was pushing
this used to work from Monsanto right
Clarence Thomas used to work for Bonsai
I mean it's just such a and it's like
people say oh this is conspiracy
theorist it's so in your face it's
beyond conspiracy it's obvious and we're
relying as consumers on these regulatory
bodies to be holding out for our our
best interest right and it's and it's in
there I mean it's in the USDA bylaws
that they have to look out both for the
safety of the consumer but also for the
safety of the productivity of the
company and you could you better bet
when it becomes that really shouldn't be
part of the Manifest shouldn't be part
of the Manifest that should be all about
the the person and not about the company
yeah we've really just uh
divested ourselves of so much control
you know and the average consumer is
just you know what are you supposed to
do yeah we we trust and rely on these
organizations to basically tell us
what's safe and what's not and when you
realize that they're compromised or
they're heavily influenced by you know
profit motive and and business and it's
all this you know cabal uh rotating
chairs you know from one organization to
the next it's that's very disconcerting
yeah it's it's strange but I tell my
patients like we've been talking about
science and all this time this whole
time but just try to use a little common
sense I mean look at the food look at an
orange peel and orange it's like created
for you tastes great it's perfectly
packaged you know who needs but you know
better packaging than an apple uh and
then think about and I have my patients
um do um a journaling where they journal
and have them Journal how do you feel
after a meal so they after you know a
high fruit High vegetable diet they feel
fantastic afterwards and the more they
notice how fantastic it is the more they
will instinctually go towards that food
whereas think about how you feel when
you eat a double cheeseburger everyone
does it everyone feels like crap
afterwards they laugh about it they feel
like crap and they go back for more
right and I I try to appeal to my
patients on this kind of instinctual
level about what do you think your
body's supposed to eat journaling is
really powerful too because most people
will tell you that they eat pretty
healthy you know yeah I'm healthy I eat
pretty healthy but when you actually
write down and you're honest with
yourself about what you're doing
generally it tells a pretty different
picture different picture
it's not going to be really revealing
for and empowering for somebody to go oh
my gosh you know I really thought I was
doing this and I now can see what I am
doing is very different like I need to
make that change yeah it's a very
powerful tool and and they you start to
notice food patterns that you might have
not thought of before you notice how you
feel you notice if you're overeating you
tend not to pick bad foods because you
say I gotta write that down in my
journal and Dr Davis is going to look at
it and how am I going to do it and so uh
and so I have found a very big part of
my practice what do you think is the
number one thing that that holds your
patients back or the people that you
treat
from grasping you know this idea of a
healthy lifestyle trajectory or what is
the big impediment that prevents them
from taking that leap protein
I don't think it's protein I think it's
this belief that we need high doses of
protein and that therefore chicken and
meat are good for you so in other words
that's preventing them from embracing a
more plant-centric approach to their
diet because they're afraid that they're
going to be missing out on something
that they need to survive yeah look well
you know I use these journals and the
patient will come back to me two months
later we've talked about eating more
fruits more vegetables I've given them
packages about what to do for snack time
eating apple and I look at their their
log and I see you know eggs for
breakfast beef jerky for a snack
Queen chicken and they always put lean
next to the chicken which you know kind
of nonsense and I'm like what happened
to all the fruits for vegetables like
well I was gonna do it but I mean I
thought you know beef jerky be better
for me than an apple because I need
protein and that's protein is it I mean
to me it's that's one big problem it's
what's driving everybody if everybody
could just relax about protein they
could start enjoying fruits and
vegetables because who doesn't enjoy
fruits
um they taste great I you know I told in
that epic trial I talked about earlier
one big part of it is I studied 500 000
people for 12 years looking at their
diets and looking awake and they
definitely saw an increase in weight
with meat eaters most specifically the
most weight was gained with chicken
eaters chicken was the biggest cause of
weight gain I tell my patients sat and
they're in shock because to them chicken
is the health food that's the lean
alternative that's the lean alternative
but it's not as lean as people think
it's not as lean as people think and we
eat more chicken than any other country
in the world how's it working for us why
we probably overeat it because we think
it's healthier so then we eat more of
right right yeah all right last question
for you if you were uh if you woke up
and suddenly you had been appointed to
be Surgeon General what kind of changes
are you making oh man I would be so
happy uh I would be so happy there would
be if there would be so many things that
I want to do some of them I'm working on
right now but there would have to be
nutrition education in Medical School
classrooms
I would work very hard in nutritional
education in high school and and Junior
High and right from the get-go including
growing
foods and farming
um I would do my I mean the farm bill
would be something I would go crazy on
handing subsidies to agribusinesses
supporting small farmers I would be you
know working very hard at Farmers that
do Multicultural crops instead of
monocultural crops that we have a more
dependable food source that's richer in
environments
I would be very big into different
cities doing community farming and
Community growth projects like that
um I'm working right now on our hospital
system changing the food and Hospital
Systems I mean is it how crazy is it
when you go to a hospital and there's a
McDonald's that just drives me up the
wall and and it sends a very important
message that uh you know Wendell Berry
said we live in a in a uh you know the
problem with the system we live in is we
live in a food system that doesn't care
about health in a health system that
doesn't care about food and as a Surgeon
General that would be my my topic try to
make the health system concerned about
food and the food system concerned about
health and what about these regulatory
bodies the FDA the USDA yeah I mean the
USDA needs to split where it's just
being concerned with health or the FDA
just just needs to be concerned with
health lobbyists need to be taken I mean
this is a this goes into a much deeper
you know now we're getting into politics
campaign Finance the whole way the
system operates yeah I mean campaign
Finance reform and term limitations and
stuff like that so you don't get these
guys that are in there that are paid by
big business I mean we've got
Republicans saying that there's no such
thing as global warming it's just it's
so anti-intellectual and they get away
with it and they get away with it
because they get paid for it so there
would have to be so much changes but I
think education would be the big start
of the focus yeah
good man I think we did it that's crazy
how do you feel like we can go on
forever so we could right I mean you
could like if you lived here you'd be on
the show all the time man I'd love to
hey I'd love to live here yeah well we
got a room for you man that might move
you have a you have a room for a Great
Dane and uh two uh screaming dogs we do
actually we got plenty of room come
anytime man
yes great thank you so the book is
coming out is it coming out in the fall
and October in October October that's
great man protein exciting yeah and
they're doing pre-sales now on Amazon oh
it's already up on Amazon
well everybody go pre-order the book
check it out use the Amazon Banner ad
ritual.com
so we can both wet our beaks on this
okay so that sounds good support the
good Dr Garth
um are you training for anything right
now I am gonna start um I'm worried
about book tours and stuff like that so
I didn't want to get too into training
uh but I'm gonna do another Iron Man I
got my eye on November 16 on November
2016. cool yeah and are you going to be
doing a big book tour yeah I think I am
going to be doing quite a bit of fun
yeah that's exciting yeah I'm excited
for you yeah go preach the word
excellent man right on well uh best way
to connect with you uh for those that
that are digging on Garth is the door to
some seriously open
um Facebook's probably the best best
place right yeah I'm on Facebook and
Twitter but Facebook Dr Garth on
Facebook so where I do most of you know
I'll print you know recent articles and
things like that and pictures of my
patients and stuff and you're Dr Garth
Davis on Twitter yes yeah and the
website is thedavisclinic.com that's
more for patients than we have weight
loss surgery in Houston so all right man
thanks for coming by thanks for having
me right on all right peace peace out
plants
[Music]